hello welcome
um I wanted to do this talk for a while
because I think it's very
useful and I don't see it happen very
often honestly this Talk's happening so
I called it get Beyond push and
pull uh and the motivation is really
that version control and maybe get in
particular because it's the dominant one
uh it's something that we interact with
every day but what I've seen over the
past decade is that we leave a lot of
power on the table which I think is a
grand shame because get permits you to
do a lot of things that makes a lot of
problems go away so I wanted to to well
show a few of
them so this talk is it's a show in tell
uh it's a you remember those from
primary
school uh it's a few slightly Advanced
operations um and I want to focus
primarily on what you can achieve with
them and I've included a wi guide on on
how to craft commits so being Norwegian
myself I know that we can be a bit of a
quiet bunch in
big um situations like this so I uh
brought some treats from Japan so if you
have a great question or you say
something clever or you're really good
at heckling you're going to get a
treat uh this is not me training you
like you would train dogs I
promise okay so this talk is not uh
because that talk exists in many flavors
it's not a deep dive into the internals
we're not going to go into the dogit
directory and it's not a tour of the
darkest and uh most scary Corners uh and
exotic
features it's not going to be an
introduction to Version Control Systems
in general
en and it's not going to be a battle of
the vcss where you compare you know this
is how you do in git and this is how you
do it in SBN that being said I had to
deal with SVN for work for a few hours
um maybe a month ago and that was very
painful so every time you open it and
you curse it count your blessings
because it could be way
worse um as a little disclaimer because
you might end up thinking that um
when would I ever do this like this is
this this would never happen in fact
I've done all of those things that I'm
going to show
today
um even when it's just me like this is
we're not actually going to get to the G
Push by the
end um
and who's seen that Version Control yeah
there we go so that's a treat for
you sorry I I'm terrible at throwing
just pass it to the gentleman in yellow
sorry I'm going to start handing them
out um
properly um this is how Version Control
used to be and we don't want to go back
there so I want to start with some good
habits uh and the motivation for
starting with that is something that a
guy I think it's called his name is
Chris but it's at least
beams um wrote very eloquently and I
said well cared for log is a beautiful
and useful
thing um blame
revert rebas log short log and all of
the other sub commands they come to life
if you care for your log so in a
previous life in a previous team I like
to say that when when you're a
programmer your product is the get log
and working code is kind of a side
effect of that so that's where you
should put your
focus uh and the reason for that is that
this is your key communication point for
for context and motivation for
everything you do with yourself with
your co-workers with your enemies and
with the
world okay
so who can tell me what this is
yes wrong very
wrong it's 69 44444 here get a
CH it is of course perfectly correct uh
a good guideline is to keep your subject
length at a maximum Char 50 character
your limit put uh the column the bar in
your editor and your line length of
Maximum
um whenever I bring this up uh I get a
lot of people complaining that it's not
the 1970s anymore and that we have WID
screens
uh
but this happens so who uses I saw jet R
is out there so it's a good opportunity
who uses
Seine okay
uh cine has git integration right how
much space do you allocate for your git
integration in your SE line does it take
up your wide screen
monitor I don't see any hands anymore so
I'm going to assume
no um the fact of the matter is that
even if you had wide monitors you don't
want to use those that that width for
just one
thing um so this is why you want to
wrap um lenus himself is actually pretty
clear on that because git does not hard
wrap sorry git does not soft wrap at all
so the only thing that you can do when
you're writing is that sometimes you
want to violate a guideline like
72 to get really long lines because it's
a URL or is something that actually
warrants it and if gift would soft wrap
it would break it and you also don't
necessarily know the width of whatever
you're targeting so the only time you
can actually encode that information on
where line should break is when you're
writing it
uh so hard wrap your your
messages if you ever bring out a g one
line git log on line you're going to see
why you want short subjects I like to
think of is that what you're doing here
is that you're writing an email and if
you ever get a subject that is pretty
much the whole message and that is more
than a quarter of a sentence you delete
the email and never read it right well
that's what I
do uh uh a good example of that so this
is GCC
right uh
and uh honestly I don't think GCC is the
best example here because they do a lot
of things wrong with
it um but for the most part the lines
here are reasonably short and they're
concise and you got a pretty good idea
of the contents of the commit just by
looking at the short
log they don't actually enforce the 50
limit um but most people kind adhere to
it anyway
um collect both user and kernel events
for auto FDO tests and auto profile
bootstrap can kind of tell what that
commit is going to do
right so okay the 5072 is not completely
arbitrary
um so as mentioned git ises not
rrap uh and if you assume 80 columns is
the width of your paper which
incidentally it was when I did the
presentation uh completely by accident
but it's it's a pretty good
guideline um and then
you leave a little bit of room for
indentation because git is kind of built
around the email thing and when you're
writing a message in your log you're
writing an
email uh you remove another 44 Symmetry
and that leaves you at 72 that gives you
a bit of room for um sort of email
replies before
overflowing and this works well across
Mo system because like usually you don't
actually allocate your entire screen
withd and Screen real estate to a get
log um the subject message is also used
in merge rebase short log and all of
these other commands so and they tend to
prefix that with things like um well
revert
merge um Cherry right actually cherry
doesn't um this is stolen from Tim Pope
in 2008 so I don't think this is very
new
information generally when you write
your messages you should uh write in
imperative this is also what git does
for itself so when you do a git merge it
will say merge and then something which
is an imperative and I added this as
examples of of in sort of uh of the
imper comperative form you add something
you remove something you prune be a
little bit careful with the word fix
because it very quickly becomes
nonsensical usually you can remove the
word fix and the sentence still applies
in which case it doesn't do anything for
you and just the mere existence of the
commit kind of implies that something
was fixed right otherwise there wouldn't
be a commit in the first place so might
as well Adit it so be careful with that
but there are cases where it's
fine generally a good
um approach a good guideline is to try
and answer the question I stole this
from from
beams
um if you apply this commit then dot dot
dot will happen and he uses these
examples like your refactor
subsystem uh update removes some
deprecated things if you can answer that
question in your subject it's a good
subject
okay when you're writing the messages
it's generally a good idea to focus on
the why and how and not exactly the what
like don't bother repeating the patch
the code can speak for itself and it's
usually much better at it than human
language uh but what you are given
opportunity to do is to summarize your
research your decisions what you tried
but didn't work think about this is the
context that you're giving your reader
when he's trying to understand why a
piece of code why a line of code is the
way it is and this is the one
opportunity you have to give all of that
context and it's also the only place
that you know will definitely persist
GitHub issues gone right because you
migrated to a different
instance the internal Wiki thankfully
that was nuked a decade ago referencing
that it's not going to work copy it into
the message it's going to be fine like
make it easy for whoever is reading it
and it's most likely going to be you to
actually just jump into the context of
what the hell this is right and add
references it's fine and the fact is
it's this this is a plain text email
which you can format pretty much any way
you'd like so you can add tables you can
add links uh you can add lists what I
like to do sometimes is that when
something happened in some other
repository that is very important I had
a case where a change in bin util new
bin utils was something I had to account
for in my program so I just copied the
subject and the first paragraph of their
message past it in into there and this
is the change that motivates why this is
happening the change itself was two
lines on its own is completely
indesirable
you can reference tickets but if your
commit message is just a reference to
the
ticket and you're under my authority
that's a firable
offense
no out of the question not going to
happen but I mean please by all means
reference your ticketing system but make
sure that the commit can stand on its
own if you focus your commits not only
in the message but in actual content too
all of the other things that you could
possibly do with your version control
system becomes so much easier to work
with you can suddenly CH pick it because
it doesn't bring in all this context
that is irrelevant but has actually
changed but doesn't make any difference
for you uh just the code review process
is much smoother because your units are
focused and they they don't they're not
all over the place um merging you reduce
the surface for conflicts tremendously
if you just carefully craft this and
it's generally just easier to understand
like your log should be
focused a signal is that if if if your
message is difficult to
write um it's usually a signal that your
commit is not focused enough break it up
into two remember that your unit in git
is not the merge it's not the pr it's
the commit that's your unit that's your
atom this too is a it's kind of a hard
rule except when it's not is that all of
your commits should pass and test we're
going to see a demonstration of why that
is important and also how you can help
check that uh a lot of things in in
Version Control generally become easier
when you can check out an arbitrary
commit and you can reliably build your
system uh it is not necessarily obvious
why uh until you try not doing that but
any automation that would
just any automation relies on everything
working all the time with what is
checked in
public history is immutable if you push
a mistake it's permanent record it's
embarrassing but you'll you'll get over
it uh what public means depends on
convention that's that's your rules
that's for you to design in some places
it's whatever is in the Master Copy on
the gitlab instance sometimes it's
whatever in the guy over there's tree U
sometimes there is no public history and
it's just one big big implementation
detail sometimes it's publish branches
anyone have any good examples of public
but not public
history
no how about
now find food is a powerful
motivator okay um when it's public it's
immutable because other people might
build off and rely on that and if you
would now change it because you can um
you would make their lives miserable
okay so let's talk about git
stage uh
anyone very unfamiliar with the git
stage it's perfectly fine yes because
then we'll do the thing see that kind of
honesty buys you another one it's green
tea chocolate promise you it's
delightful here we
go okay so git operates in two phase
commits and git has a clear distin
between what it knows about what it
doesn't know about and what's on your
file system and they're not the same
thing
um before you make a and this is a
common criticism of get that I don't get
because honestly the two- face commit is
a
feature um when you make a commit in Git
it will not necessarily reflect the
state of the files that you have in your
directory in your tree right so that's
what it means you first need to add it
to this special magical staging area
hence the name and when you do type or
run git commit it will grab whatever's
in the staging area not on the file
system and in fact what you can do as an
exercise is that you can add something
to your stage delete the corresponding
lines from
your file system from your work tree and
you can still commit it and git will be
happy
um the alternative would be that your
Version Control System would just
snapshot whatever is on your system
sorry on your on your disc at whatever
at the time you do it so you stage your
changes adding them to your index before
as as a preparation
stage um and I think a good
demonstration of that why that is so
powerful is what I would argue is a
mandatory feature again if you're
working in something I have authority
over if you don't do this again fire
offense get add dot is just blanket
ban
um so uh this is
GCC um what I'm going to do is I'm going
to just undo the last
commit and here you see it's a bit of an
underscan
here make a bit bigger I maybe that is
fine
actually
um
there we go okay so uh we now have some
changes if I run get diff it will show
me the
changes there are I don't know what's
that 60 lines something like
that um and if I now start doing get ads
patch can do the long short form is p it
becomes muscle memory very
fast what it will do is sorry it will
prompt me and ask do you want to add
this to your index or
not and in this case I
do yes thank you very well thank you
very much prey to pleas with sugar on
top uh I don't want this one so I can
say
no um if I now do the
status uh you can see that in this file
I have some um changes to be committed
and some not Stang for commit in the
same file so what this permits you to do
for example example which is very useful
is that it permits you to have a dirty
tree full of print statements and extra
debugging information that is very
useful for development but that you
don't want to check in without having to
change your files before actually giving
them to
get um and what it allows you to do is
you allows you to create commits that
are much more focused than if you would
just add whatever's on the file system
this should be the default operation
that you're doing so you can do a get
commit um add some stuff don't do that
[Music]
um and now you see I still have some
changes here in the even some files in
the tests that I didn't get to be
prompted about with Git ad P because
patch mode will or git ad without any
file path will only consider things that
it already tracks these files aren't
tracked in the first place yes
question
see right so um what said is that he
would recommend always doing a get diff
staged to check what is actually staged
before the commit before actually
performing the commit what you can also
do is you can commit and then
immediately log it and see see what
happen so there clever
comments uh some green tea
chocolate
yes
yeah if you do dashb you already got one
though so you'd have to
wait I only have room for so much
cleverness before I run out and then
it's going to be Riot uh yes so you can
also do uh- V to see this as you're
going about
okay
um is it check out Master is
it
okay actually that's Upstream
Master Okay anyway I'll fix that
later
um
reset who uses reset occasionally yeah
see there we go this is very good um
reset is a beautiful thing usually you
just do it to undo whatever's on the
stage but you can do more than that um
it also supports patch mode which pretty
much does the same thing
right
uh actually it's a pretty good
opportunity to do
that um so one it allows you to just
reset whatever is on the
stage
um but you can also do it
with
revisions so obviously this command is a
bit boring because now we only have the
one hunk
right uh but what I would do now if I
would actually apply
this
[Music]
um this now shows me
what's um what's in the stage which I
can now also reset properly
right
um and you can do that with specific
files and you can even go further back
right
so what you can do with that is you can
specific surgically pull things out of
commits in your
history uh which is pretty
neat okay kind of needed that one uh
just a question so what clients do
people generally use forget command
line okay it's about maybe 23s
tortoise very nice whatever yours were
called
smart get quite frankly I don't care
what client you use right none of my
business my interface with you is not
your client my interface with you is to
log if you're happy with your client mug
it em maxers yeah there we go a man of
culture oh another one
brilliant um use whatever client you
want I don't care about the client
you're using I care about the results of
you using it I personally like the
command line if you want to point and
click that's fine I don't care about
that um but I do care about you putting
some care into your interface with the
rest of the
world um check out supports path two
this is very useful if you have some
dirty changes in a file that you just
want to go through and like some of
these you want to discard completely and
just take whatever is already committed
uh but it's too much work to do this by
hand actually figuring out what was
really there before so uh this is mostly
use
when
um um when your tree is somehow dirty
right so you can do so what's our log
here okay so we can do get check out was
it
head
patch and then even the path which is in
GCC just now works with directories but
you can give it specific files and you
can do this as many times as you'd like
um and now it's asking me do you want me
to actually discard this change that is
in the file tree so it's in the file
system but get hasn't acknowledged it
yet and it now allows me to just write
it away and reset what obviously now
there's just one big hunk but you can
imagine there being many small changes
with lines and so one thing is that if
you had for instance added a lot of
print and debug
information you you can do this to then
um hunk by hunk discard everything that
is a print without having to manually go
through your file and do it with your
editor it's a very powerful
thing
um real world example
from me uh I had this whole directory
that used to do a thing that we didn't
need anymore so I killed it but I needed
to look it up uh for a
reference uh on how to do something
where I wanted to bring kind of parts of
the functionality back but definitely
not all it and I wanted to just keep the
reference around so I could keep it open
in my editor while moving it about so
what I did is I I went to the commit
before this remove
happened uh notice how I used the the
ter or the final slash to indicate that
this is a directory so you don't need
any more information in the subjects is
very concise and say okay so the file
that was there right before you deleted
directory please give me that the way
that it was so that I can just open it
um fundamentally get us a database
right so that means you can ask it
questions and you can actually get
information out of it and this is an
example of that it's a file that isn't
if you just check it out it's not in the
tree but if you do a bit of digging you
can sort of revive it and it comes back
as a zombie and you can pull out
whatever you want and then just delete
it afterwards because you know that g
has your
back right thank you
again okay building histories
um who I don't know if anyone here
actually has maintained or worked on a
large code base that you kind of didn't
write that you wanted maybe to backport
some fixes to because you're very
specifically needed that one version but
with that extra little bit of
feature um but sometimes what you want
to do is you want to
splice patches really you want to splice
changes that happened later in the
history onto some other
Branch really or onto some other reality
so that's what the Cher piic is for most
other operations or the two other sort
of fast forwarding mechanisms in get
with the merge and the
rebi kind of work on ranges right and
they they expect it to be a a continuous
line Cher pick pretty much relinquishes
that and allows you to just um pretend
as if this was written into the work
tree
uh without this long chain of changes
preceding
it uh I wish I had a really good
demonstration for that by hand I suppose
we can make one
[Music]
so um what I can do can at least
try uh is I have a
patch let's
go I think
there no
uh I guess we can even try this one
actually so it should for the most this
one will have some conflict actually so
it's even better example
um we can take this we can just try and
apply it to the tree as it is now and
now we get some conflicts in the
documentation
lovely okay so we're going to abort that
but what we're now doing is that where
actually the conflict is in the driver
um so we can fix that with merge
tool and try and fix them by hand
usually it's something trivial like
this and yeah done same thing here
just for the demonstration I'm not
actually going to check if they're
correct all right good so now we have on
top of this
branch do the one
line uh a commit that was never
designed for this Branch I just you know
take it from over there this is often
how you backport things is that
something has been fixed Upstream but
you need it for the 2.38 release so you
just grab the patch and apply
it
um
can anyone tell me what this probably
alludes
to oh come on one has to
know okay so get is pretty famous for
being able to do one thing that most of
the others don't really do uh which is
the
pattern well merges yes and get is scary
good at them but this is a particular
kind the three yeah I I'll that's not
the one I'm going for but I'll accept
that this is of course the octopus
merge uh what happened once in Linux uh
was that they got something that Linus
dubbed the culu merge uh git permits you
to merge several branches uh at once and
usually you do you know merge to two and
two merge this PR thing into Master
that's how most upate on it but you can
take n branches if you'd like which is
called an octopus merge which will give
you mer commit with more than one
parent uh in in lenux it happened that
one had like 32 or 36 parents or
something and L called it the the Cula
merge which I it's pretty
amusing
um merges generally work very well if uh
every single change is focused right
because you don't want it to
accidentally step on something that the
other Branch might have done when there
is no reason to
um anyone have an idea why you would
want to do an octopus merge over just a
pair this one use case really and it's
when you want to merge all of these
history all of these
branches uh as long as there's not a
single conflict otherwise abort then you
don't have to do it piecewise so because
come this Atomic merge it's very n thing
but sometimes
useful I'm not going to show that
because requires too much infrastructure
rebase whenever I hear the question do
you merge or do you rebase I'm want to
scream silly
question uh so one way of looking at is
that if you have two branches that you
want to somehow unify you using merge or
rebase U end up with exactly the same
state afterwards except that in the
merge case you have an extra commit
that's the
difference um the problem is that rebase
is an overloaded word which we're very
familiar with with C++ and all uh so you
use the rebase command for all kinds of
useful
things uh but the Practical distinction
of merge and rebase for uh creating a
new canonical state is just not
interesting who's used
that yes many brilliant then we can be
very quick about it um so rebase
interactive is a beautiful thing so have
let's look at this
log uh and we do just five
right kind of dull too because we have
the daily bump and merge Upstream
runtime okay so what we can do is that
we can do interactive and then
inter
active it's very hard to type in this
standing up but slightly awkward um and
here this opens your
editor and now you're able to do a lot
of things that it's actually pretty
neat uh and git is very helpful uh in a
very you know strong Unix tradition and
it tells you the commands that you have
so you can take a commit and you can
pick it you can reward it if you'd like
you can edit it you can squash it which
means merge it into the previous one but
edit a message uh fix up which means
merge it into the previous one but
discard the
message um you can run a command or or
you can
break drop is an explicit form of
something that you can otherwise do and
I have actually never ever used label so
I don't know what that
means uh so for one thing we can say
that you know what we don't actually
want this DMD nonsense so we just delete
the line which is equivalent to
drop um and then we want to reward daily
bump because this was written by my mom
so there's a bit of a passive aggressive
note to it
and now if I do the same log on line
thing you see that the uh
DMD I did I drop it maybe I didn't
actually I meant to drop
it drop okay
good you can see that the message for
the daily bump has
changed uh and the DMD thing is gone
right
now don't do this to public history
public history is immutable but this is
very useful because it allows you to
snapshot and Stage what you're doing in
your work tree as a part of your long
development cycle because you're solving
a hard problem you can snapshot that
commit to your heart's content never
ever run a risk of because it allows you
to do destructive in place uh changes
and then you just you know put some
makeup on at the end
brilliant um there is nothing worse than
having having a 2 and a half thousand
line change which kind of does one thing
but kind of doesn't and now you need to
figure out how the hell do you actually
break this up into something that can be
reviewed because if you're sending me a
2500 line diff then you can rest assure
that I will not look at it I would
either bin it or just merge it which is
neither is a good
option uh so rebase interactive gives
you access to all these powerful
features to rewrite your
history I do not care how your history
looked like your machine until you
submitted it to me rewrite to your
heart's content whenever someone says oh
yeah I want to see how you got there I
don't want to see how you got there I
want to see your concise precise
surgical steps in order to produce the
result that you want I don't care what
it looked like in the meantime if you do
everything pristine if you do the right
from the top and not a single mistake
fine if you like me kind of go a little
bit back and forth and maybe throw in
some experiments you don't want to see
that trust me you do not want to see
that
and then you have this one is probably
my favorite git feature and the one that
starts the journey for most people so
who here hasn't heard about
it okay good beautiful honesty I will
throw this one at
random sorry I realized as I threw it
that's might hit someone in the face and
then I would get sued
um sorry about that but enjoy Okay so so
get fix up commit fix up I just call it
fix up usually allows you to do
something like this so we'll just get a
file let's do I don't know GCC and
then backend. AG that's a good one and
say no we don't want this bit map in
here it's going to crash and
burn and and say that oh let's do one
line it's actually a part of the daily
bump like this is getting a really bad
commit because not only is a daily bump
with the passive aggressive triple dot
but it also just randomly deletes and
includes
so you do get commit fix up and then you
give it a reference so here I'm copying
the hash this could be anything that get
considers a reference it could be uh the
name of a branch it could be a tag you
could do the relative head Delta 5 there
is even a thing where sorry where you
search on a commit message by regular
expression and then pick that one which
is beautiful I'm not going to show that
now but it's in a manual and I have done
it on occasion uh oh so I need to add it
see two face no we don't want that
change we only want the bit map
change see now I didn't even I didn't
even include the wies space change that
Vim did very helpfully for me with the
backing. age uh thing I just want the
bit
map uh including see the file is now
dirty but has one file changed one uh
deletion fix up daily bump and what it
really does is that it just creates to
commit with this particularly formatted
message fix up exclamation daily bump
dot dot
dot okay
um just discard everything in a working
tree duas
interactive uh
head
four now what has happen is that git
has helpfully moved the fix up line to
the right place if I didn't have Autos
squash turned on it would look like this
but get recognizes this pattern with the
fixup commit that when you do rebase and
a pafy call called Autos squash which is
I just put on by
default it moves it up there so that
when you now merge this or sorry when
you run
this
um it's going to be gone from the
history and if you look at um
if you look at the daily
bump the contents of the
commit it now also includes this sbit
map AG
brilliant um so what that allows you to
do is that allows when you're building
your change could be one commit could be
10 commits and then you
realize I actually wanted this change
here that I happen to just notice it's a
yspace change maybe it's a type
annotation maybe you added a con that
you want to put into some commit that
actually is earlier in the history that
you still haven't published but in your
tree you can just mark it fix up get add
commit because obviously we have two
phase so you only have to add the
changes you care
about um create that commit and just do
the rebase Autos squash at the end right
which allows you to do driveby changes
that kind of belong somewhere
else uh and then focus on whatever you
were doing get it out the way
so I do this all the time usually when
I'm working on
something 12 15 fixup commits is not
uncommon so that's the Autos squash it
you need that along with the commit fix
up for it to really work to really shine
um there's a setting
yes
yeah
um so the question is if you the when
you if you do a lot of fix ups and then
you do the auto squash thing so that
they get merch into the commits and then
you want to see how many fix up that
happened can you do that I mean the
answer is technically yes and it's a
good segue into something called a ref
log um but it's kind of irrelevant
because they melt into as if you'd
written it correctly the first time so
history looks like you're brilliant and
you get everything right on the first
attempt which is how you you want to
present yourself to the world um but uh
it is a very good question you can you
can but it's pretty uninteresting
information at that
point good question okay so using
histories short log uh who hair does
releases kind of frequently of their
software okay do you write change
logs yes no so on average you're kind of
okay
right so uh Jason here automates them
someone like some people write change
logs some don't if you don't then shame
on you change logs are nice uh get short
log
uh this one is going to take forever
because it runs on well kind of forever
runs it on all on GCC you can run this
on a range of commits so let's do is it
release GCC 120 Z to
head is it
not 12 3 0 one Zer that's fine to head
so what it computes
is what authors it groups it on the
authors you have a few options there but
it groups it on the
authors want commits got entered and
here here it just picks the subject
right this works very much better if
your subjects are concise and short and
precise um so it just groups in on the
author between these two points in
history who wrote what commits this is
pretty good to base your change log on
this of course assumes that
your um log messages are actually good
and accurate and provides you useful
information but it's a good starting
point uh it's one of those things that
make writing the good subject actually
pay off
um this is a cool demonstration so
remember that all commits should pass
your tests
right
um they should like every every commit
should should pass the test but how do
you do that when you have now five
commits and maybe something introduced
something breaking it could be a syntax
thing it could be a test that was
missing so one way to verify that is to
go back to good old rebas right uh so I
actually have a demonstration on
that uh I wrote this
pretty um brutal shrip
which
um builds and tests a
project
right and then I want to see because now
my uh let's do n six right
and I want to test it on this because
this is my branch that technically
hasn't been merged
yet um so what you can do if you do rebi
and just pass it
exact and now you give it a command so
in this case I've done it in a shell
script because the um let's just make
sure it's clean yes um I've done it in a
sh script because it's sufficiently
complicated if you if your build step is
you know python build or something you
don't even need to do that you can just
give it a shell command
directly um consult a manual for
everything
else uh so you can EXA you do the same
range head
six and it's SE
rebas whoops failed on the the script I
guess
uh isn't it build
DD
oh well now it was a
dollar uh and build python if you can
spell as much
better um okay so we abort that attempt
it didn't
work
um BCT something yeah just remove it and
then you run it again so this is what
happens very often I I up the
command and then I just abort and try
again this is kind of in place and
destructive but it doesn't matter you
can you can work with that because it
doesn't actually ruin
anything okay so that commit
pass that commit passed okay so you see
how the story goes right and now it's
just a quick verification on the end
just run it through
right
uh
well then I guess butter
up so so what happens when the build
times is two days yes so I mean there
are some practical limits there's
another reason why you want to try and
limit things like build time but in some
projects this might be
impractical um maybe you can then run a
more concise test maybe you can do
something more precise maybe not in that
case maybe even your build system would
cash sufficiently because the changes
are small enough that you can just reuse
your entire SE
right okay so I mean if you're brok in
your build then it doesn't work um so
how long was that maybe 40 seconds to
determine that my now six commit pull
request uh still build some
tests
fantastic what you can do even is that
you can keep some of these scripts
around that just do your endtoend test
check it into the repository and just
make a habit of running rebas EXA
whenever you're unsure in practice what
happen happens is that when every time
you make the commit you have already
just done the build and testing but if
you do a lot of history rewriting and
reordering then maybe sometimes it get
messed
up
BCT guess what the question is who's
tried it who's done
it all right good that's a surprisingly
healthy number bisect is one of my
favorite features in get this feature
relies 100% on your builds testing and
building every time and I'm going to
demonstrate it on GCC uh but full
disclaimer I have cheated a bit because
GCC build times are too long for this
demonstration um so what BC does is that
it permits you um to set a start and end
point um of your history where you think
your state is good and you think your
state is bad probably because you find
some regression and then essentially
binary search that range for the commit
that introduced a
regression um and here I have to do the
there we go the typing a bit
carefully but let's see it's rev list uh
I made the Tag because I did this in
advance uh Indy first
bad with
releases GCC
1220 so somewhere in GCC
1220 this was fine and at the commit
that corresponds to NDC first B it was
not fine so somewhere in between
that
[Music]
releases just count and
that's
commits where's the
bug it's it's in there somewhere where I
promise um so this is how it works it
takes a bit of it takes a few attempts
to actually get going with this it pays
off and I have done this to find just
remarkable bugs incredibly fast uh get
BCT start so you do bisect start just to
tell the Machinery that you want to get
going there is a short hand for this but
it's more obvious if you if you do it
like this and then
um bad and this see first bad right so
you're telling this this commit you know
is bad I mean the first one that you
know is definitely
bad um then you get by say good and you
give it some other reference which is in
this case it's going to be releases GCC
12 to zero
right and it doesn't preliminary work
and now I have a
script which I called
test um it defines some pretty colors
and then this is the cheating if the
directory corresponding to the commit
already exists don't rebuild it because
then we' be here for a while and it's
almost
lunch
um and then it runs the test
specifically that I know is failing and
it's uh the analyzer um test with fails
with unexpected
failures in which case you print the red
this commit is bad and otherwise you
print a good um and this script uh uses
exit codes to communicate if it failed
or not so I run the test for this
commit and it runs for a
bit okay thank you right this commit is
good this kind of what we expected right
because we already told them that this
one is
good um so now I can say okay get
BCT good there are a lot of more
Provisions to this did I say 200,000 it
must have been 20,000 I can't read
apparently uh this of course is very
tedious so get allows you to automate
that um get BCT run and then
your your test right and this here you
can do a plane shell command too if
you'd like I've done it in script
because it's efficiently complicated
sometimes you can just run a test you
know cat a file or grap for the error or
something like that is also fine it's
just an arbitrary command that Returns
the status code
uh 2,000 to test 1100 to test well 1
1200 to
test um of course binary search is
logarithmic in complexity so our 20,000
commits corresponds to about 12 or 13
jumps
um okay so that one's bad and you can
see that it even runs to test and it
finds the number of unexpected failures
is three that one's bad 73 revisions
left six
steps so this goes on for a bit
obviously if you have to build this in
your two di thing then it's going to
it's going to be a
while but at the same time it's probably
faster than doing this by hand and
finding the 20,000
commits
right
yeah that well that probably doesn't
help um okay four revisions left now two
steps in a property of the binary
search and
finally timing is not my thing
apparently um so this is the final step
and it has to determine which one of
these two is
it and it now shows you the commit that
failed which is in total about what is
that 60 lines change so we've taken
20,000 commits and reduced the bug
surface down to 60 lines in what was
that three minutes something like that
all right Applause thanks very
much all
right um and in fact this is the commit
that does introduce the bug which is
fixed
Upstream you can then do the log and
it's going to show you what commit it
tested and with what
outcome as well which is quite neat it
can allows you to replay it and
visualize it yes
question
right right so the question is if if you
if you didn't have a test back then
there's an excellent question that um
reproduced it how would you do it then
and the thing is you can build and run
arbitrary things in here and you can
even do get so what I did on one
occasion is that as a part of my test
script I did the git checkout from The
Sibling Branch get this file into my
work through and then build it you can
you can run tests on things that g would
otherwise considered dirty in your work
tree and it's going to be fine so you
write a test and this is often what
happens is that you find a regression
you create a test that reproduced a
regression that is not checked in
anywhere and then you run the bisect
against that test that you still haven't
checked in until you figure out where
the source is you fix the bug and then
you commit the test so it's an excellent
question and usually when you have
regressions you have them because you
didn't have the test in the first place
so that's actually the common
case well done okay so to patch or not
to
patch who's used format patch
before okay so who did it because they
did something on the mailing list
somewhere one okay it's a pretty strong
reduction uh format patch does pretty
much exactly what it says on the
Tim uh it takes a revision or a range of
revisions and it creates patches diff
files that anyone can apply this is a
gorgeous feature that pretty much comes
from the fact that Linux is developed on
the mailing list
right uh I have used this outside of the
open source mailing list context on
several occasions with good success uh
for example we we got some poor interns
uh in for a summer job uh and being a
big company obviously nothing works so
it took them about a week and a half to
get access to the internal GitHub
stuff uh we didn't want them to sit in
their hands for about a week and a half
because we had them for six weeks it's
kind of inefficient by to spend of time
and I wanted them programming right away
so I just gave them a task which I
didn't do a very good job with he isn't
here so he's not going to punch me uh uh
he's friend of mine and he would he
would have liked that uh so when I said
okay just format the patch and send it
to me by email and I have never seen a
gaze so blank in my life
before uh he figured it out and he just
sent me the patch applied it and it is
the first his first commit in the tree
wonderful um so I'm going to do a quick
demo because it's uh so you do get BCT
reset by the way to get back to where
you started just quit it
um a lot of files in this but so you can
do git format patch and typically we
just do uh sorry head and then from the
previous one git creates a patch file
for
you um 001 add something
something and what you can now do is you
can take this patch I can send it to you
by email by direct link FTP upload you
can write it on a postcard and you can
copy it I mean it would be fine and you
can apply to your tree and now we have
shared histories and shared patches with
no shared
infrastructure uh so for example what
happened to me recently at work is that
I was trying to build something with
some
internal project uh and it didn't build
because there was a bug in the build
system because they didn't account for
something can't remember what it was uh
and it was two line fix so I just fixed
it but of course I didn't have right
access so I couldn't create branches and
the internal GitHub thing was defined so
that you couldn't do Forks how do you
make these people how do you give this
change to them so what you do is you do
format Pion and say hey please apply
this and and do whatever you want
because now you don't need any
infrastructure
anymore uh kind of an is thing uh for
most workplaces I would assume because
you have a functioning Central instance
but when you don't this is getting a
pinch also if you have very aggressive
renames this might be the only way to
backport changes because what you would
do then is say okay so here it says the
the file was config I 386 MD we know
that it has the capital I so you can do
that which is pretty neat you can just
change the patch in line or
live um okay good send email does I'm
not going to demo that because there's a
bazilian flags and all of a sudden I
bombard someone with an
email but it works pretty much as you'd
expect it will take your patch series
which you can give it and then it would
package them into an email or an email
series you can add your cover letter you
can send your
CC's and it will then send these Patches
by
email so the question is now that you've
sent Patches by email what have you
given your recipient any
idea well a problem usually because now
they have a bunch of patches and an
email they don't know what to do with
fortunately you're here so you know that
you can do get am which is um English
for apply
mailbox
um
obviously uh so so this is the Dual of
of format patch this will take a mailbox
of these patches and apply it to your
tree
um and uh so that one would be actually
cool to demonstrate so what we can do if
we can please forgive me because it's
not going to apply for the same reason
that we did before but uh we did the PI
right uh anyone
remember I don't know it's
somewhere I guess it's here
right so yeah here we go fix up dump
it's most definitely that um this one's
good
okay um so you can do format
patch and then
I guess it's something like that
yes um so now I have a mailbox with
these
patches uh and obviously this is now not
in um in my current tree right so what
you do is you
get G am and this can either take a file
range or you can do the thing where we
read it from standard
in and now we have uh the same sort of
merge
uh thing oh actually we don't all right
um if you need this assumes by the way
that things apply
cleanly uh fortunately git has been used
before and you
um can tell it to try to three-way merge
if you need to and now get merge tool
works as you would expect right see the
exact same problems that we had
before uh let just kill
it
okay so now we have the same
patch
um BL one line there we go we have the
same patch now apply to our tree but
there was no chry pick involved and this
could have been across different hosts
so that's that's the
mailbox if ever you work with mailing
list or back porting or AC cross big
project with mixed structure this is the
way to
go
um git log s is pretty
great um so most do git log and maybe
git log patch sometimes so you can see
the diff as you're going sometimes you
want to search right uh so it has this
git log s thing where you can now do git
log s and just do lbb or something it
allows you to search for a string and it
will now give you a series of commits
where where the else BB string shows up
in the diff apparently it's a pretty
long time ago so we need to search for a
while like most of the things can get
you can restrict this to directories you
can restrict this to ranges oh there we
go so yakob did this sometime in
2022 uh the lbb string showed up in his
death and maybe we can
even um see
it uh
yeah there we
go if div needs device adjustment else
BB somewhere so what you would typically
do is you would start out with a very
unspecific string that you know kind of
reles and then from that you would get
the context to just keep on
repeatedly um specializing
that uh that string uh git
grap uh kind of not so what G grap
allows you to do is to well grab for
things but only the files like it knows
about so if you have a very dirty tree
it's very convenient to skip out and
anything that's dirty but it also allows
you to do it you know across revisions
and across directories and
histories um you can play with it it
behaves mostly like grap but it's gware
does pretty much what it says insta web
now you don't need GitHub anymore this
my
favorite
um
I happen to have two dogs in there so
what this gives you uh is just a very
quick
visualization yes question time is are
we out of time we are it is lunch but
it's good because this was basically the
last
one please reach out send me an email
come mug me afterwards uh I
have two left best question gets it gets
one each yeah
or otherwise it's lunch um please send
me an email pretty much about anything I
want to develop this into a course if
you're interested let me
know um yeah thanks very much for your
attention all
right